Notre correspondante
Tamara Alteresco.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On peut condeseseses heures
sans jamais croiser personne.
♪ ♪ ♪
Des centaines de kilomètres
de steppes et des routes
de poussiè
Des troupeaux de moutons
traversent à l'improviste,
en quête de verdure,
car plus on avance,
plus c'est jaune.
♪ ♪ ♪
Nous roulons sans aucun
itinéraire, là où le vent
et le sable nous mènent.
Ici c'est le désert qui
pousse et non les plantes,
d'incroyable
en bordure des villages.
Celui d'Erdniyevskiy tient
le coup, mais la vie est dure.
ququququques enfants et
des fermiers surtout,
comme Igor qui a tout perdu.
Cette ferme était sa grande
fierté. Ilstststststruite de ses
propres mains pour les 50 vaches
qui faisaient vivre sa famille.
Au total, 40 000 bntntntntntnt
mortes de faim ou de soif
emportées par la pire sécheresse
de l'histoire du territoire.
Nous sommes en république de
Kalmoukie, un pâturage autrefois
unique, où des décennies
d'agriculture abusive sous
le régime soviétique ont mené à
l'érosion presque totale du sol,
une situation déjà désastreuse
qui est aujourd'hui exacerbée
par le réchauffement climatique.
♪
"J'ai envie de pleurer",
dit-il, en ravalant ses larmes.
Sa détresse résume celle de
milliers de personnes dans cette
république, la seule bouddhiste
de tout le continent européen.
Des fermes abandonnées hantent
les steppes sur la route quièèèd
qui se vide, 100 km plus loin.
L'hôpital n'est plus.
Le centre culturel est
laissé aux cochons.
Il reste au moins cette école
devant laquelle un chameau
monte la garde.
C'est ici que Rimma,
71 ans, enseigne la biologie,
sa passion depuis toujours.
"La Kalmoukie, dit-elle,
est méconnaissable."
"Quand j'étais petite,
l'herbe m'allait aux hanches.
Et aujourd'hui, vous voyez
ce qui se passe?", dit Rimma,
en nous amenant à la fenêtre
de sa classe d'où elle voit les
dunes pousser d'année en année.
Elle y amène régulièrement
ses élèves pour mesurer
l'ampleur de ces enjeux
environnementaux qui forcentaiaà
l'exil. Il y avait mille élèves
autrefois dans cette école.
Il n'en reste que 70.
Altusha, 15 ans, nous explique
avoir déjà fui son village natal
parce qu'il a été englouti
par le sable. Elle craint que
la même B B B B B B B B B Berga.
"Et c'est ce qui nous attend,
prévient Rimma, si ça continue."
"Il n'y a pas eu une seule
goutte de pluie de juin
à septembre, pas une seule!"
Et c'est sans compter qu'en
moins de 10 ans, la température
moyenne a augmenté de 1,2 degré.
Avec un te
presque impossible de renverser
la tendance et barrer surtout
la route aux sables.
La désertification gruge
désormais 80 % du territoire
Kalmouke.
"C'est un cauchemar
et un cercle vicieux",
explique Svetlana Ulanova.
Elle dirige, avec très peu
de moyens, toute une équipe
de scientifiques à l'Institut
de recherches sur les sols
arides dans la capitale, Elista.
Ce sont eux qui financent
les travaux de leur poche
et elle prévient que le pire
est à venir, car les réservoirs
d'eau sont en train de sécher.
"Le réchauffement climatique,
dit-elle, accélère
le processus."
Nous avons pu le constater
à plusieurs reprises
en sillonnant la Kalmoukie.
Les bassins se vident et ce
qu'il reste d'eau est beaucoup
trop salé pour la consommation.
"L'eau est livrée par camion
et rationnée dans plusieurs
régions", dit Svetlana.
"Les gens non seulement
commencent à comprendre l'effet
du réchauffement; ils le vivent
et en payent les conséquences."
"On se croirait en Arizona
ou en Oklahoma", dit Chongor,
un jeune fermier, qui porte
en lui 400 ans de tradition
kalmouke... et quelques
exploits. Grand champion
national de la tonte de mouton,
il nous guide ce soir sur ce
qui était autrefois un lac.
Quand le soleil se couche
en Kalmoukie, les gens prient
pour que la pluie tombe, mais
elle rare même cet automne.
Hongor est aussi un père de
famille et un citoyen déterminé
à protéger son territoire.
La dégradation du sol
le trouble, le climat aussi,
tout comme l'idée de voir
ses enfants quitter la région
comme tant d'autres le font
aujourd'hui.
"Les Kalmoukes sans leur steppe,
c'est comme du thé sans lait,
dit-il, une tradition sacrée,
comme l'élevage des moutons,
aussi dur soit-il de nos jours."
Car chaque matin,
c'est la même routine.
Hongor se lève avec le soleil,
monte sur sa moto et pousse
son troupeau, là où il y a
du gazon et des plantes.
"Parfois, c'est 10 ou même
20 km. Et en raison de la
sécheresse, on ne peut plus
exploiter toujours le même
pâturage. Le gouvernement
a imposé des limites sur
le nombre de têtes de bétail,
mais personne ne les respecte."
♪ ♪ ♪
"La nature nous parle",
dit Hongor.
"Et ce qu'elle nous dit,
c'est que je vous traite
comme vous m'avez traitée."
♪ ♪ ♪
Des paroles sages qui traversent
tranquillement les steppes,
un village à la fois, là
où il y a encore de l'espoir.